beim Thema Wohnungsnot ist ein
Lösungsansatz natürlich auch das
generationsübergreifende wohnen zum
Beispiel ein junger Student zusammen mit
einem Senioren ja gut okay also ich
finde Wohnungsnot ist ein Thema übrigens
gibt es aber nicht nur Studienorte in
den Hauptstädten sondern auch irgendwie
etwas weiter draußen das ist manchmal
noch besser mit dem Finden einer Wohnung
er bringt auch Cannabis mit in die WG
ist das ein Angebot nee das ist kein
Angebot und ich würde sagen wäre auch
gut wenn man sich vielleicht noch mehr
auf die Studieninhalte und weniger auf
Cannabis konzentriert das würde der
Volkswirtschaft auch helfen aber da
drücke ich die Daumen geschafft er will
auch gar nicht mehr bei ihm